not only will i be looking to see how
much i can improve
but i also want to experiment to see how
we can
sort of
take all of the things that link offers
in terms of input-based learning
and connect that to a tutor hi there
steve coffin here today and today i want
to talk about using
a tutor at link and specifically with
reference to
my persian learning remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review i
appreciate it
so
if you've been following me you know
that i've been sort of bumbling along in
both persian and arabic
and arabic i've been sort of
experimenting with you know mainly
standard arabic but a little bit of
egyptian a little bit of levantine
and so i've decided that for the next
three months i'm going to focus on
persian
i'm going to work more closely with my
tutor sahara one of our tutors at link
you know that i'm primarily an input
based learner so i've been doing a lot
of input in these languages
somewhat lazily largely focused on
listening which is easy to do
uh trying to find the time to do some
reading
if i only have a short period of time
i'll maybe review my vocab
focusing in on the status three words
where i'm likely to know them so i can
move more words to known i'd like to get
my known words total up over ten
thousand
i have about twenty seven thousand
saved words in link
but i have less than ten thousand known
words and i'm sure a lot of the words
that are in that status three
area i i in fact know them but i haven't
come across them again so that i can
move them to known
from experience i know i can easily find
a few hundred or more
there so that'll move me over ten
thousand so those are the kinds of
things that i'm going to do in terms of
input continuing my input activities but
i want to explore the ways in which
a link learner like me can work more
effectively with a tutor
so i spoke to sarah i said i want to
experiment over the next three months
and we're going to look at the different
things that we can do that will sort of
integrate link learning which is
predominantly
sort of
using
input content things we can find on the
internet or beginner material
to move our learning along and we don't
spend as much time talking about output
but we all want to get to output i want
to speak persian better
so
what are we going to do first thing
twice a week i'm going to speak to sarah
i've already scheduled that in
and we are going to have a subject so
we're not just up until now i just
arrive and we talk
uh sarah keeps a record of my mistakes
for vocabulary that i was missing she
sends me a report which she records i
review it
and occasionally i'll go back and review
previous lessons and that's kind of been
it so now we're saying we're going to
have a specific subject
so she for example has proposed that we
talk about the economy of iran of turkey
because she happens to be visiting
turkey and they have inflation and other
problems there and the economy of canada
so with that
i say okay i'm going to prepare for that
so what i did
was i googled
uh first of all i convert you know the
economy of iran the economy of turkey
the economy of canada convert that into
uh persian i cheat i use google
translate to do that i put it in the
search field
and
i see what pops up
now typically wikipedia pops up pretty
quickly
and we have permission
to use wikipedia articles
at link so these are persian language
wikipedia articles
i'm going to
study those
and sahara is going to record them for
me so that gives me some material to
start to focus in on that
the
vocabulary surrounding economics
another
source for persian material persian
language material is radiofardo
and there again we have permission that
link to share
content from radio free europe
radiofardo a lot of that is also very
good so that's going to give me some
more
on vocabulary and in that case i have
the podcast
and i use happyscribe to
transcribe the podcasts and so i can
learn from those
and the agreement i have with sahara is
that she will decide the subject for
tuesdays and i will decide the subject
for thursdays so she gave me the subject
of the economy in those three countries
and i've decided that i want to stay
with that vocabulary so that i'll get to
know it better so i want to talk about
inflation so tomorrow i have another
session with sarah and we're going to
talk about inflation and again she will
create a report
and send it to me with the recording
so i'm hoping to you know
getting back to my discussion of the
uh
hockey stick i've sort of progressed
past that steep
blade of the hockey stick stage
and i'm somewhere here i'm not sure
where i am but i'm at the beginning of
that long road from b1
to b2 i consider that to be the longest
stretch
some people say
no the longest stretch is from b2 to c1
i mean it's kind of arbitrary because
unless you actually take a test and i
don't take a test but i consider b2
means i'm comfortable i make mistakes i
understand most things
uh c1 means i make far fewer mistakes
and there's nothing that i don't
understand but i'm not
quite at the
level of vocabulary of a native or c2 so
i don't know how far that distance is
all i know is that this long road to me
is the most uncomfortable
because i'm not good enough to
understand
most of what i hear on these persian
language podcasts i'm not good enough to
have a comfortable discussion about
the economy or inflation or whatever so
i want to get to here whether this is
closer to c1 or not so close to c1 to me
this is the most
uncomfortable stage we feel we're not
getting anywhere we feel we can't
remember anything and yet we're not good
enough to just listen and read once we
achieve what i consider to be this b2
stage
where
you know
i can just listen to persian i can just
talk to people make mistakes doesn't
matter i'm comfortable i can watch
movies so i'm not as good as i would
like to be but i'm comfortable that's
where i want to get to question is three
months working hard with
uh sahara
uh is that going to enable me to do it
okay i also want to demonstrate to you a
little bit of how i set up to focus in
on
content material that's going to help me
get there
i'm also going to leave you some videos
of me speaking persian
so that at the end of the three months
we can see if i improved or how much i
improved
another purpose of this is to see
working with zahra
what are the ways in which we can better
integrate
link functionality link content
links ability to access material on the
internet how do we integrate that with
working with the tutor
what are the what can the tutor do tutor
can follow my activity level
can prod me nudge me to do more
and so over the next three months not
only will i be looking to see how much i
can improve
but i also want to experiment to see how
we can
sort of
take all of the things that link offers
in terms of input-based learning
and connect that to a tutor providing
you know content that we can work we can
work on together whether it be from
beginning beginner material that we
already have in our libraries or
accessing material on the web maybe it's
the tutor helping me find things on the
web so that the tutor becomes more of a
guide perhaps a guide to link a guide to
content on the web
a coach
on this sort of path where we want to
get again picking up my hockey stick so
we're going here here here now we got
this long road and i'm looking to see
how much a tutor zahra in this case can
help me achieve my goals so
uh
that's what i want to do check out my
little walkthrough
you know of what i did on the site and
check out the videos
where i speak persian and we'll see how
much i improve
thank you for listening bye for now
so i want to show you how i generate
content
on the economy that i can use to prepare
for my
discussions with my tutor
so first i said economy of iran
and so i cheated a little bit
and i translated on google translate and
i put it in the
google search field
and uh
something comes up so it's related to
crisis
but it's going to have the technical
terms that i require so now i need to
get that into link
so i can go to my browser extension here
and click on it
and i have already created a course
called economics
so i just click on import
okay
so
all right
so here's my lesson now
uh there are
other ways if i go to edit lesson
i can see that i have other lessons that
i have brought in in the sort of
economics banner here
um
i don't have an audio file but because
this is wikipedia
we are allowed to share it
so
but i don't want to share it without
audio so i have asked my tutor to create
a recording of this and what happens
then is
once i have an mp3 file
and and you can see here at the bottom
of my screen that i have been
uh getting uh recordings uh mp3 files
from radio fardo
which i transcribe uh at the
happy transcribe and then but the point
is you just take one of these mp3 files
and drag it up here but i'm not going to
drop this because it doesn't correspond
to this content but when i get uh when i
get a an audio file from my tutor i'll
put that up there if i want to change
the name of this i could call it
something else
uh you know economy
of iran
but uh whatever it's up to me for the
time being it's only for my own personal
use so i have no description and i don't
worry too much about how it looks
if i go to share this now i'm going to
have to improve it
and
so
i can now go back to viewing the lesson
all right now
the other thing is if i wanted to i
could also
just simply or maybe like so
whoops
whatever
yeah copy and paste
so i copy it
then i go to link and i go to import
import lesson
and if i didn't want to use the browser
extension but it's so much easier with
the browser extension but
i then could select a course so if i
choose economics ec
and search is going to come up
so i could select that and and if i
select it and then i can add another
lesson i'm not going to do that now but
so that's another way of doing it and so
i sometimes use the browser extension
if i'm dealing with
you know transcripts like these here
that i've gotten from my
mp3 files that i extract from the radio
fardo podcast then of course i i copy
paste and then import it in in this
manner and and then add in the audio
file so that was just to show you how i
go about doing that if you have any
questions please let me know